has there been somebody who in the last
like year you realized was like a fan of
what you were doing or was following you
or someone who like liked something that
or just dm'd you like a that was just
surreal for you to be like damn this
person knows who I am like they
acknowledged my art like in
2017 Meek uh pay like Meek like Coan for
me them yeah that's fire he on and then
growing up like he's the reason why I'm
really rapping like so you were like a
big Meek person yeah I was a big big
Meek fan growing up and I was like if he
could do it I could do it Dream Chasers
all they did was doubt him you know he
was self made [__] doing a battle rap so
everybody didn't think that he could
cross over mhm and he crossed over and I
remember being in high school walking
around like yo he going to be the next
thing I'm telling you I'm telling you
and then he started going crazy did you
see his uh his latest the funk Flex
freestyle that just dropped I actually
was I I was with them but I had to leave
because I went to my um release party so
I wish I could have you got to go to
your release party yeah I had to go to
my release party today but I I
definitely was chilling with Rick um I
was just like yo me freestyling for
minutes straight I'm like this [__] is
like [__] 12 all over again I missed
it like that right there is
inspirational for me like I'll be neing
to see that but you know it's online
anyway so I always just tap into it for
sure so are do you have a friendship
with with Ros and meek at this point
yeah like we like that's family that's
dope yeah that's family for sure do you
get a like being family with Rick Ross
do you get like a Wing Stop card or
something I ain't I you know what's so
crazy I should have asked him for a
plate of lemon pepper wings man i' been
like hey bro like what's the point of
our friendship if I can't get some sort
of half off or restaurant like let me
get a gift card a gift card would be
nice I feel like he should have his
wallet should be as sick as mine cuz I
got like a old white guy wallet and
every time he like yo thank you you
real you know what I'm saying don't hurt
you like lemon pepper is that the go-to
um I wasn't I got put on to lemon pepper
not too long ago maybe like two three
years ago and my first time eating it
was in Atlanta oh yeah yeah but what
spot in Atlanta I don't remember I just
remember having lemon pepper in Atlanta
though lemon pepper's fire it's fire
well done too well done mhm I'm I'm a
buffalo guy but I I'll dabble in there
see I used I used to do the Buffalo but
now I don't like I don't like it to be
too messy cuz I been working so much so
I need to eat things that's and then
your you get your nails done your nails
will be all orange underneath well but
the thing about me is I'm low
maintenance as a female so I ain't
really are those your real nails are
these are these the oh so those your
real your real boys right there for sure
shout out to you yeah real so my wife's
Mexican and she you know she gets fake
nails but she eats Hot Cheetos and [__]
so oh so the Cheetos and all
cheuck Hot Cheetos lemons and pickles on
a plate nah mind your business leave her
alone ain't nothing ain't hard to find
some water and soap she can wash her
hands you know uh talk about uh
obviously this record with with Bryson
is dope um shout out to Bryson who
doesn't do many features no he doesn't
do a lot so it it's got to be you know
dope to be able to kind of like get a
he's he's one of them guys you know what
I'm saying yeah Bryson just was telling
me like hey I rock with your movement I
think you're a dop dope artist and and
he he did what he could do he did what
he do like he always do he don't miss
and I'm grateful to have that because I
know when Brayson pop out it's a reason
for Brayson to pop out for sure he's
like an introvert for like big time yeah
like he just I think he's just more
focus on music more than anything yeah
like it's not even a it's not it's he
don't focus a lot of people a lot of
artists focus on the lifestyle as well
but with him I feel like he just focused
on the music more than anything yeah
thing um being from Brooklyn are you are
you like a Nicks or a Nets person or do
you not give a [__] don't put me in that
don't mm I'm I'm you want to get back
from both teams you want to do half time
at both teams right don't do me like
that man but
listen shout out to the [__] shout outs
they're both really abusive
relationships as fans I'm sure listen
I'm I'm I know the Nets is it's it's new
right you're from New Jersey yeah okay
well then it is what it is don't put me
in a sports thing I don't know I don't I
don't know you're so don't I'm not about
to sit here and be lying to y'all I just
like to watch the game I don't care what
game it is I have you been to more Nets
or Nicks games I've been to more Liberty
games honestly shout out to the Liberty
shout out to the Liberties they just
went to the finals yeah get me but we
did you go I didn't I couldn't I
couldn't make it I wanted to go don't do
you remember when Rebecca Lobo was on
the Liberty do are you I don't think
you're no I'm not I'm not like all the
way I just started tapping into when the
WNBA started they had this giant white
woman on the Liberty her name was Lobo
she played for the Connecticut uh huskys
she was just this Giant mountain of a
white lady she was really good at
basketball she was good yeah how much
she was doing on on the game what points
you was putting up I can't I I'm I'm not
going to lie a you don't know that far
huh female basketball's gotten a lot
better recently it's no it's got really
good when I grew up it was like we had
like Cheryl swoops Lisa Leslie Lobo
listen I love there was like there was a
part you know maybe 10 years ago it was
just hard to watch but now like you know
the lities is doing shout out to the
Liberties those my girls Laney you heard
have you performed at a game yet like
any I try to I I try to do what I could
do I did Liberty I did next game I did I
think I did the next twice so you're a
Nets fan [__] the Knicks I'm kidding I'm
kidding they ain't had you perform [__]
them we we rocking with the Nets they
had you perform twice come on man Mel
Bridges is over there that's a for shout
out to the Nets they take care of me
love they really do take care of me all
the time shout out to them and they just
gave me a gift not too long ago thank
you what they give you I can't tell you
what Noe what gift could a basketball
team give you that you can't talk about
because it's only it was I could say how
many it was limited and it was only like
five and I was one of the FES was it a
Jersey no it was it was a package oh you
got a package it was
huh tourn oh the in tournament thing is
is it
yeah listen your new your new album is
out yes Dennis daughter um everyone
should go support it are you going to be
uh hitting the road anytime soon of
course I'm trying to go on tour for sure
Dennis daughter got to promote Dennis
daughter project that's the only way
it's going to move did your mom
obviously your your dad passed away but
is your mom like hey the next album my
name yo listen I'm telling you this
right now my mom's was like listen
Dennis you doing too much bro you doing
a little bit too much what's your mom's
name t so album Number Two tisha's
daughter tisha's daughter I'm not going
to tell or the deluxe the Delux how you
know yo listen all right cool you look
at me look at that Kev Kev done the
deluxe the deluxe is tisha's Da Edition
there's a situation where I'm feeling
like a deluxe should be put out I can't
tell you when but a deluxe should be put
out Deluxe on the way she says now did
not say that she all all but said it
I'll tell you that much isn't a good
idea it's a good chance it could be
happening for sure is it cold in New
York in
December no it's not okay well you live
so you're used to it it's [__]
freezing anyway appreciate you coming
through thank you for having me Kev I
appreciate it Lola Brooke boom fire uh
and then we'll we'll do a quick like
like a little two or three minute we'll
talk about the album and then yeah all
right here we go yo it's the bootle C
show man uh look we got this young lady
her new album is out right now she's
taking over the show Dennis daughter
Lola Brook is in the building uh uh uh
how you feeling I'm feeling good um just
dropped Dennis's daughter feeling
excited I got some closure now it's time
to celebrate at the same time work this
project uh yeah look the album uh is
fire uh shout out to uh your team I mean
I know you've been working on this album
for a
while this particular
project close to a year about a year
okay well is your first album first ever
so so for you uh talk about like
obviously you got some big features on
here what was it like working with
Bryson tiller like where were you at
when you first got his vocals
back I was in Florida nice yeah and I
remember it was just like weird type of
Vibes and they like everybody looking
like they just they being sneaky then
they like look listen to this so I'm
listening I'm like okay yeah then his
vocals came in I
said this is real
and like we could put this out like I
was excited so shout out to Florida
Miami Florida cuz that's when the first
time I've heard uh Bryson on you um talk
about right now I feel like we're like
in the I always say like the uh I would
say like in 2017 18 the New Renaissance
of female rappers kind of kicked off but
now it just feels like you guys Run rap
so like referring to someone as a female
rapper kind of out the door because
y'all kind of like Run rap music now um
who are some of your peers that you just
like you know obviously you worked with
a lot of dope female artists but like
yeah like lot of city girls go crazy I
love sexy sexy red is amazing sexy red
is aming she's out here on tour pregnant
running it up running it up pregnant and
working like the the I'm sorry no guy
can say they outworking sexy red that
girl is pregnant right now and she has
no shoes on most of the time music
videos whatever so God bless her and her
health because she trying to make a way
for her and her family for sure uh your
album uh talk about just like if if
anybody's listening on the radio right
now and they find you on Spotify what uh
song are they going to first and what
what type of vibe we in let's say we we
had a party we had a party we gonna um
make a pit stop at the pit stop with
Lola Brook in French Montana oh shout
out to French shout out to H shout out
to French Montana New York goat all
right so look the album's out let's get
I'm going to let you introduce your new
single which has Bryson tiller on it
it's going crazy let's get into it uh uh
you already know the Vibes it's your
girl Lola Brook and this is my new
single You featuring Bryson tell hey yo
bootleg Kev what up with it let's get it
fire